So we have a
look at encryption,
but remember that TLS is
made up of two parts--
encryption and hashing.
Hashing is the process
of transforming data
into a short representation
of the original data.
The smallest change
in the original data
will have enormous
changes in the hash.
If two documents yield
the same hash value,
they are very very likely
to be the same document.
There are a couple of
things we care about
with hashing functions.
One, it should be impossible to
revert the conversion process.
Meaning once data has been
converted into a hash,
it can be unconverted back
into the original data.
And two, it should be
just as impossible to find
a different document yielding
an identical hash value.
One of the most common
hashing functions
is SHA, which exists in
multiple flavors like SHA-256,
or SHA-512, where
the number says
how big the output of
the hash is, in bits.
No matter how big the
document is, if you pass in,
you will always get
256 bits as output
when you are using SHA-256.